when it comes to building muscle or
getting fitter there are a lot of
divisive topics and one of the most
divisive topics is whether you should
use full body training or a bro split
so a full body routine of course is any
training regime where you're training
your whole body with each workout so
that might mean that you're doing some
kind of metabolic resistance training
circuit or it might just mean that you
go around the gym use lots of different
stations but make sure to train your
whole body as you do then you have your
bro splits and these are splits where
you will train different body parts on
different days so one day might be your
biceps one day might be your laps one
day might be your pecs or maybe you'll
train one or two or three body parts in
a single session but either way you're
training them not all at the same time
but which is better and why do people
argue so much on this topic well the
full body routine has a lot going for it
a full body routine allows you to train
with more frequency so you're training
each muscle group four or five times a
week and for many people frequency is
one of the most important variables for
encouraging growth and fat loss etc
getting into the body that they want
training with your full body of course
lends itself better to more compound
exercises and functional exercises
things like squats and benchpress
and hands down press ups calisthenics
because you're using your whole body as
one unit instead of just isolating
particular muscle groups full-body
routines also lend themselves better to
metabolic resistance training style
circuits that lends itself better to
HIIT in many cases it's great for fat
loss because you're using your whole
body the heart has to pump the blood to
the top and to the bottom because you're
using all the muscles you're releasing
more growth hormone etc and so this is
another reason a lot of people prefer
full-body routines it might even be
according to some research that a full
body routine increases your gene
activation which means that your body is
going to be more metabolically active at
all times to build muscle and burn fat
it also seems that full body routines
are better for increasing the
testosterone and lowering cortisol and
so in general many people just think
they're better for all-round performance
and fitness and strength on the other
hand a bro split or just a split routine
allows you to focus on each muscle group
and give a much more intense workout in
that area so you're going to do things
like your bicep curls and then pull-ups
and then hammer curls and then overhand
grip curls all in one workout and of
course that Aussies really torture the
biceps crate
lots of micro tears buildup a lot of
metabolites you know it crude the blood
and just that area build-up all the
growth hormones in that area and then
give it a whole week to recover and
remember that we build a muscle during
recovery not during exercise and so this
is also to some people a reason that the
bro split is actually better for
building more muscle in specific areas
i've talked on this channel a lot about
the j wider training principles and
that's the kind of thing that a lot of
split routines will rely on and there's
no way that you could train every muscle
group as intensively in a full body
routine and not be completely destroyed
and also just take too long you couldn't
do all kinds of giant sets and drop sets
and run the rack on every muscle group
or you'd be in the gym for hours so that
makes more sense if you're going to be
trying to really punish the muscles the
which is better and what should you do
well of course a lot of it's a matter of
opinion and also comes down to your
biological type because some people
respond really well to frequency and
that's the thing that's missing from
their training i've seen people who were
really skinny couldn't build any muscle
and then when i started to train every
single day i even need so many train
twice a day they just balloons because
their body really responded to that
other people's bodies really respond to
that kind of brutal intensity followed
by a long rest period and one of the
reasons that a lot of body builders use
that kind of training is because they're
on steroids and so they can recover from
a much more intensive workout and also
they don't cannibalize the muscle as
quickly during their resting phases for
me personally i often like to do both i
do think there's a lot of merit in using
a split routine i've got my very biggest
by using a split routine and like i say
i just can't do i like to do really
giant sets just focus on one muscle
group and use things like drop sets and
mechanical drop sets enforced reps and
burns as i've talked about just to
really punish that muscle group and
create a lot of growth and i can't do
that with a full body routine I don't
think that I could build as much muscle
you know aesthetic muscle big muscle
using a full body routine but on the
other hand the full body routine allows
me to be much more agile and to burn
more fat to get much more toned physique
so I'll often do both I'll do a week of
doing split routine then I'll do a week
of doing full body because that's just
the kind of way I like to Train I do
what I enjoy I'd do it for fun
I do it for research and so there's no
reason for me to stick to one or the
other I kind of just do whatever the
mood takes me today I was filming a
rocky workout so I was running around
and I was in pull up some trees and they
went to the gym and I was doing presses
and things so you know mix it up you
don't have to stick with just one thing
and by doing that you might find what
your body responds best to and of course
also depends on what kind of muscle you
want to build but you don't have to
cheat
thanks you don't have to choose between
one or the other there are some kind of
compromise options and one of my
favorites is push-pull legs or ppl so
basically this means that on one day you
train with all your pushing movements
and one day you're training all your
pulling movements and I'm one day you
train your legs or I sometimes call it
push-pull lower because you can do your
legs and your abs on the same day so on
the push day you do things like bench
press press ups overhead press tricep
pushdowns then on the pull day you do
things like pull-ups curls lats
rows etc and so that way you're not
doing your whole body but you're also
not just isolating one muscle group you
can get quite an intensive workout by
grouping just you're pushing muscles
together enough to get a real burn on
the muscles that you're targeting but at
the same time you're still using your
body as a functional unit and you're
still giving yourself the option of
frequency because you can fit push-pull
legs obviously into a week twice or you
can do it just once and have lots of
recovery it's a really nice versatile
one I think it's great for beginners
because it gives them that intensity
also a lot of time to recover and also
the option to not be too intense and it
makes a lot of sense because in reality
very few exercises are truly single
joint exercises if you're going to be
training your pecs
chances are you're also training your
triceps and your shoulders a little bit
anyways so you might as well involve
them more so and do a push workout where
you time it all together and that also
allows you to do things like pre-exhaust
s-- where you'll train that muscle group
before the other one or to focus on
specific areas of your pushing motion
for the functional types a lot of
functional exercises are either push or
pull you're either doing pull-ups or
you're doing press ups there's very
little where you're pushing and pulling
equally in a single exercise so if you
can't decide between full
body or split routine and try push-pull
legs but either is a good option it all
depends on what your goals are and I
recommend to give both the go and ppl to
see what works best for you so thanks
town for watching guys hope you found
the video useful and interesting if you
did please leave a like maybe share it
around and comment down below and let me
know what you thought thanks so much for
all your support so far it means the
world to me I've got more like this on
the way more bodybuilding brain training
nootropics fitness parkour martial arts
productivity starting a business from
home if that all sounds good then stay
tuned and I'll see you next time bye for
now